c'était en janvier 2016 une visite des
élus sur le probable futur terrain de la
nouvelle prison de lure un engagement du
président l'an devenu quelques mois
auparavant au sud est de christine
taubira qui était venu allure les ânes
ont passé un nouveau président a été élu
l'ancienne prison a été démolie n'est
toujours pas nouvelle à l'horizon alors
des questions se posent des politiques
comme michel raison le sénateur
s'interroge
il en a fait part à l'actuel ministre de
la justice nicole belloubet depuis lors
la purée et la dernière fois que j'avais
croisé le changement de majorité
présidentielle des nouvelles
orientations changent la donne
pointée du doigt dans ce dossier le plan
immobilier pénitentiaire du gouvernement
qui devait être présenté à la fin du
printemps 2010 8 et qui se voit
repoussée à l'automne puisque selon le
cabinet de la ministre de la justice
il n'est pas prêt mon cas rien n'est
fait pour lui roumain quiétude des élus
eurent à un projet à un terrain des
dépenses ont été engagées pour faire des
études
des promesses ont été faites très ferme
aux élus je pense que
l'équipe gouvernementale actuelle doit
tenir les engagements de ses
prédécesseurs
nous avons joint par téléphone le député
de la circonscription christophe lejeune
apparentés république en marche qui
reste lui confiant sur le dossier
avançant même un projet renforcée
carcéral pour la prison de lure dans le
traitement des maladies psychiatriques
et psychique et dans celui de la
réinsertion l'arbitrage gouvernemental
aura lieu en automne prochain
et ici allure il est très attendu